before the time when colon was known as
a great warrior who battled the
executive douchebags by leaving the
Tonight Show
so it's glorious legacy could be
preserved PS you got balls there was a
dollar Kona played by then relative
newcomer Arnold Schwarzenegger
I am the nostalgia critic doing a parody
of the great and powerful medical art
I'm a high adventure
solvers and sorcery and great epics this
large in scale smaller intelligence corn
and movies were based off of the great
stories written by Robert E Howard but
from what I understand they have almost
nothing to do with these illusions so we
will instead look at the films
themselves they are films before
one-liners before the great explosions
and people dental work to fix everything
gap in between your teeth yourselves for
phenomenal goofiness okay I'm not gonna
do that pressure the whole time but we
were gonna take a look at these movies
and our first film Conan the Barbarian
starts off oddly enough with a Fredrick
Nietzsche quote well give him credit I'm
certainly gonna be telling myself that
while watching this movie between the
time when the only joke already next
so we start off with Arnold
Schwarzenegger as a little child as his
father gives him some helpful advice no
one in this world can you trust that men
and women let beasts this you can trust
yeah how about your village is attacked
by savage killers whenever you greatly
and are so blood hungry that even their
dogs are dressed up in armor but your
trusty sword won't do much there what
maybe you should consider that strength
in numbers strategy
[Applause]
so as Conan's father is killed in the
nights playing whack a villager his
smoking-hot mother tries to protect him
from the evil James Earl Jones
[Music]
[Applause]
well gee when you put in like that
[Music]
so it looks like he's gonna leave her
alone and let her fight another day
[Applause]
[Music]
yes I enjoy taking a long time killing
that person for no particular reason
I sure hope her son doesn't build up a
vengeful rage and dedicate his life to
destroying me while also working on his
gigantic leave large pectoral muscles
knock on wood
so all the children from the village are
forced into labor which is strange
because the men and women would not be
sleeping much stronger more valuable but
what do I know maybe they work for less
and where exactly do they take these
children yes coming you won't be
spending the rest of your life pushing
this wheel years and years of tortures
may that will go by as you'll be asking
yourself why am i pushing this wheel you
will never get an answer to this
question however it does seem that your
muscles will spontaneously quadruple in
size all from pushing this relatively
pointless but also very lovely wheel
secona grows big and strong as he
literally spent several decades pushing
this damn thing do you think he enjoys
it by now I mean good lord a lifetime of
doing nothing but working out what does
that do to a guy it's a satisfying to me
as coming is you know I was having sex
with a woman and coming I'm like getting
the feeling of coming in the gym I'm
getting the feeling of coming at home
I'm getting the feeling of coming
backstage when I pump up so I'm coming
tonight
I mean it's terrific right good for you
:
comer you as the rest of the wheel
pushers seemed to disappear somebody
finally comes together
no no I said give the children candy not
have them push a gigantic wheel in a
circle continually for the rest of their
lives
how did you even hear that yeah push
wheel set pair push wheel though all I
understand is wheels
please do you have a weird may I push it
so corny and I suppose is bought and
forced into fighting for money and I
guess all that wheel pushing paid off
because even though he's never had any
combat training he's apparently a really
good fighter and keeps winning event
after event he was taken to the east a
great pride language and writing were
made available hmm how to speak with an
Austrian accent the scroll is very
informative but over time Conan becomes
angrier and angrier and I guess his
master is afraid that he might have
created a monster
Conan what is best in life to crush your
enemies see them driven before you and
they hear a lamentation of the women
very good corner you get a gold star
thank you sir
may I have a real bounty shaka wealth so
it's master sets him free to wander
aimlessly and she comes across some sort
of burial site
ladies in the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull
Crom now yes crumb crumb I suppose is a
way of God who helped discover the
invention of Steel and is also the
winner of the god with the stupidest
name competition
[Music]
[Applause]
so after he grave Rob's beloved crumb he
comes across a woman in the middle of
the hills as it appears she may have
some information on the man who killed
his family I know it crash this stinks
if he had thanks did you see snakes
why'd it have to be snakes simple
pattern a shield two snakes coming
together coming in the gym I'm getting
the feeling of coming at home all day
tearing and coming
but in order to find the treacherous
villain he needs some directions
unfortunately she tells him that there's
a horrible price to pay honking the
living shit out of her Wow how come more
mental as for directions this is
wonderful
Oh naw she's pulling me into avatar D
features will be stunning but this story
will be absolute bullshit
[Laughter]
Hey
so after that he comes across a thief
named Subba tie who says he can help him
find James Earl Jones by traveling
across the land
[Music]
behold we have reached to lucidum wait
what
so they go to a few towns get drunk II
punches a camel that's nice and they
even come across another thief who joins
them on their quest I'd like to ask her
for directions
there unfortunately capture though by
king Osric played by next month I know
he I suppose has a task for them he
promises them riches that they can bring
back his daughter who's been brainwashed
by James on jobs she follows him I just
like seeking for the truth of her soul
as if I could not give her the power of
crime compels her Conan dresses up in
his silliest outfits and decides to
fight Jones alone he rides off into the
wilderness and sits camping some sort of
Stonehenge what the horses just died
with them don't worry Wilbur we'll catch
those bad guys what you did oh okay I'll
just stand here until starvation so it
turns out James Earl Jones is the head
of a brainwashing cult which is pretty
much like Burning Man if everybody
dressed up like Tylenol but Conan is
spotted and brought before our villain
Steve isn't strong boy flesh is stronger
look around you there on the rocks a
beautiful girl come to me my time
that is power crucify him
- Jewish forgive them Crum they know not
what they do
methinks whereas he's nailed up right
next to Eric I always look on the law
side of law but the other two thieves
come to save him as they take into a
wizard will try to bring him back to
life and wouldn't you know it he's
played by Mako so he gives him a Mako
over as apparently this is supposed to
bring him back to life somehow all right
what's an eight-letter word for an
uncouth person in the dark ages begins
with people anybody anybody but begins
would be so Arnold Sudoku seems to work
as Conan is brought back to life but
there's still the business of gang the
king's daughter back as they try to
break into the castle and get her out
bye guys have fun storming the castle
they trust haven't there commando makeup
that still doesn't seem to camouflage
anything as they sneak into the palace
where some sort of strange orgy is going
on
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's just silly
[Music]
does he do this often is Thursday night
just snake night
oh well no time to question logic now
we've got a princess to say they take
her away from the palace as James Earl
Jones finally comes to his senses guys I
told you to watch the place well I was a
speak can't a guy just be a snake for
five minutes without something going
wrong so he gets out his bow and I'm
totally serious here he fires a snake at
them you know guy I can see you have
sort of a snake motif going on here but
you don't have to use it for everything
just use a freaking arrow I mean what do
you brush your teeth with snakes comb
your hair with snakes god help us if he
actually has a snake condom that you'd
be insane so the woman sadly dies as the
rest of them get ready for the big
battle they do this by setting up the
Flintstone equivalent of home alone
traps
[Music]
I've never prayed you before all that
matters is that two stood against many
that's was important
vclav pleases you crime the bad news
I'm afraid
your prayer accidentally got intercepted
by our crumb the perverted cartoonist
they was sexually attracted to Bugs
Bunny and I I cut out this Bugs Bunny
off the cover of a comic book and carry
it around with me so grant me one
request
crank me revenge
and if you do not listen then the hell
with you
Wow that's like the most backhanded
prayer I ever heard in my life give me
what I want and it's not possible
do you think you'll just pray for
everything like that from now on Oh
crumb please let my happy meal contain
either Alvin Simon Theodore from the
Alvin and the Chipmunks collectors
series but do not put it in each event I
do not like to do that I can't be older
Taneatua pets in there there isn't you
pet hair wheel so with this fear magic
helmet he fights on all the bad guys
along with his friends so for the oldest
trick in the book hitting a helmet which
I thought was you triggering a rock
activating a spear to stab me in the
chest at damn your gourd he even gets
help from beyond the grave apparently
do you want to live forever
and buy forever I mean a brief cameo in
the sequel so he wins the battle as all
the bad guys flee back to the palace
they snapped the princess to her senses
as she agrees to show Conan how to sneak
into the fortress and finally kill James
Earl Jones
[Applause]
[Music]
my child you have come to me my son who
gave you the will to live
what will your world be without me my
son well gee when you put it like that
fuck you
Oh Oh
so I guess this somehow breaks the spell
they're all under I didn't even know
they're under a spell as Conan runs down
the palace and Hills up some height for
the scene in time he became a king by
his own hand
this story shall also be told very
poorly in Conan the Destroyer